un disco rota inicialmente en sentido
horario alrededor de un eje fijo con una
rapidez angular omega 0 en el momento te
iguala 0 2 fuerzas f 1 igual a 20
minutos y f 2 igual a 10 newtons son
ejercidas sobre el disco como se muestra
a continuación vemos en la gráfica que
estas son las fuerzas y además indican
las direcciones que gráfica muestra la
velocidad angular del disco en el tiempo
antes de ver las opciones vamos a tratar
de dibujar la gráfica a nosotros mismos
pausa en el vídeo y traten de dibujar la
gráfica de la velocidad angular del
disco en el tiempo en el eje vertical de
la gráfica está la velocidad angular y
en el eje horizontal está el tiempo ya
que nos interesa ver cómo cambia la
velocidad angular en el tiempo cuál es
la velocidad angular inicial nos dicen
que la rapidez angular es omega 0 y que
la dirección es en sentido horario la
convención típica es que el sentido
horario es negativo y el sentido
antihorario es positivo así que
comenzamos con una velocidad angular
negativa que indicamos acá y es menos
omega 0
recordemos que omega 0 es la rapidez
angular por lo que es la magnitud de la
velocidad angular y como es sentido
horario la dirección es negativa ahora
veamos cuál es la torca neta en la
gráfica vemos que f1 va hacia abajo y es
perpendicular al radio del disco que
llamaremos rf2 también va hacia abajo y
es perpendicular al radio f1 proporciona
una torta en sentido antihorario
mientras que el eje 2 proporciona una
tuerca en sentido horario en la gráfica
se indica que f 1 es más grande que f 2
y ambas están alejadas del centro de la
rotación por lo que la torca neta irá en
sentido antihorario es decir que irá en
sentido contrario a la dirección inicial
de la rotación la torca neta es positiva
lo que significa que la aceleración
angular también es positiva y la
aceleración angular es la tasa de cambio
de la velocidad angular la cual será
constante si suponemos que estas dos
fuerzas son constantes observaremos que
al inicio el disco rota en sentido
horario pero conforme pasa el tiempo va
a ir más
hasta que llega un momento en el que la
rueda cambia de dirección de rotación y
comienza a rotar en sentido antihorario
con mayor rapidez cada vez la gráfica
debe ser más o menos así ahora veamos
las opciones que tenemos al ver las
opciones nos damos cuenta que la opción
a luce casi igual a la que acabamos de
dibujar así que es la opción correcta
pero veamos qué es lo que describen las
otras opciones la opción se implica que
la rueda inicial rotando en sentido
horario pero que acelera en ese mismo
sentido horario el cual no es el sentido
en el que la torca está siendo aplicada
por eso descartamos esta opción la
opción b implica que la rueda inicial
rotando en sentido antihorario que
sabemos no es el caso y por eso la
descartamos la opción de implica
nuevamente que la rueda inicial rotando
en sentido antihorario y después va
acelerando en sentido horario esta
opción podría confundirnos si no tenemos
bien clara la convención de que el
sentido horario es negativo y el
antihorario es positivo también
descartamos esta opción y confirmamos
que la opción correcta es y con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente